MATT BRITTIN: So let's give a
very warm Google welcome to
James Cracknell and Beverley
Turner, please.
Welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
MATT BRITTIN: Have a seat
on the comfy chairs--
BEVERLEY TURNER: Thank you.
MATT BRITTIN: --here with us.
So welcome to Google.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Thank you.
MATT BRITTIN: And it's the
first time we've met.
But James and I met a little bit
when I was crashing out of
the bottom of the British
rowing team as he was
escalating his way up towards
a couple of gold medals.
So it's very nice
to welcome you.
BEVERLEY TURNER: We
want to work here.
MATT BRITTIN: You want
to work here?
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES CRACKNELL: No, you
don't want to work.
You just want to have
a [INAUDIBLE].
BEVERLEY TURNER: Yeah.
I don't want to work here.
I just want to have lunch here
and use the library and the
gym and sleep in the library.
[LAUGHTER]
BEVERLEY TURNER:
Obviously, no.
MATT BRITTIN: Don't give
anybody ideas.
That's not what we
want them to do.
So maybe we could start the
conversation with--
and we'll give everybody
a chance to have a
chat with you as well.
But we were just looking at some
video there, which was, I
think, the beginning of James'
race across America, which is
when he had a bike accident.
We'll talk about that as well.
But Beverley, just tell us a
bit about what that was.
What stage in your
life was that?
And what was James doing?
BEVERLEY TURNER: Funny enough,
James has never seen that.
So that was actually the first
he's ever seen that.
I was actually giving birth the
day that transmitted on
television.
So I vaguely remember
watching it.
When he was actually
doing the trip in
America, it was July 2010.
And it was a coast to coast
trip for the Discovery
Channel, could he be the
quickest man to go under his
own steam using Olympic
disciplines, because it was
2012 as well.
So running, cycling, rowing
and then swimming to the
Statue of Liberty, that
was the plan.
Anyway, he got as far as Arizona
and then ended up
spending a month in hospital,
which was
definitely not the plan.
JAMES CRACKNELL: Odd that
you should laugh
whilst saying that.
[LAUGHTER]
BEVERLEY TURNER: It's just
so ludicrous, really.
So we're two and a half years
out from the accident.
MATT BRITTIN: So two and
a half years later.
And James, you were watching
that for the first time.
You haven't seen that
footage before.
Do you remember much of it?
Or how much do you
remember before?
JAMES CRACKNELL: I remember
that was the bit as it was
going into the round.
I remember that stage of it.
I remember actually right
up to where I
got hit by the truck.
So we left from Santa Monica
Pier, which is the
end of Route 66.
So I got into Death Valley.
And then I was running through
Death Valley, which is about
75, 80 miles, and then
back on the bike, up
Route 66 to Lake Erie.
And then I was going
to row Lake Erie.
And so I can remember the bit
of Death Valley was just--
I think, it's just been
re-awarded the hottest
temperature ever recorded
on earth.
And it was 50 degrees.
Even at night it
was 40 degrees.
And I think it probably went on
to say that I consumed on
the run, which took about,
maybe, though 18, 20 hours,
something like that--
MATT BRITTIN: So that was 18,
20 hours to run how far is
that, really?
Is that three marathons?
JAMES CRACKNELL: I said between
75 and 80, I think.
MATT BRITTIN: 80 miles?
BEVERLEY TURNER: It was three
back-to-back marathons.
JAMES CRACKNELL: Yeah.
I wasn't [INAUDIBLE]
pacing it.
MATT BRITTIN: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES CRACKNELL: It was
more fairly steady.
But still, I drank 35 liters
of fluid in that time and
still lost eight kilos.
It's just so hot.
And you get running past signs
that are minus 100 meters
below sea level.
And don't stop, turn your
air conditioning off.
Though I actually hadn't
any when I was running.
But it is a pretty brutal
place, considering it's
developed country.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Horrible.
Horrible.
I was actually there to watch
him finish the run stage,
which is unusual, because any of
the trips that he normally
does are so remote that you
can't be there to give him a
hug, because he crossed the
finish line in the South Pole
or whatever it is.
MATT BRITTIN: But this
was near Vegas.
[LAUGHTER]
BEVERLEY TURNER: Yeah.
MATT BRITTIN: So this one--
BEVERLEY TURNER: You
spotted that one.
I like that.
Yeah.
So I'd had a weekend in Vegas--
[LAUGHS]
MATT BRITTIN: Yeah.
BEVERLEY TURNER: --and then
drove into Death Valley.
But there's no mobile signal.
It is appropriately named
Death Valley.
It's brutal.
It's a horrible environment
to be in.
And James was at the peak
of his physical
fitness, I would say.
I think, even as a rower for all
those years and having won
two Olympic gold medals, I think
he was at his physical
peak, actually, at--
what was that, 38 years old.
About 38?
Yeah.
JAMES CRACKNELL: Yeah. as I
mentioned, I was piggy backing
of two guys who were
pretty good.
So otherwise, you're running
on your own.
MATT BRITTIN: Yeah, we're
not buying that.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT BRITTIN: We'll come onto
what you've been doing
subsequently in a minute.
But just fill in the blanks
a bit for me, James.
So when I knew you, you were
sleeping on people's floors
and eating baked beans
out of a can and
trying to break into--
BEVERLEY TURNER: Oh,
he still does that.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT BRITTIN: --trying
to break into the
British rowing team.
You then had a couple of
Olympics which were
frustrating for you.
And then you won a couple
of Olympic gold medals.
And people will probably
know that about you.
So just tell us a bit
about that you won
Olympic gold medals.
And then you became this bold
adventurer type with that
slightly camp guy from the TV.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Yeah.
JAMES CRACKNELL: [LAUGHS]
MATT BRITTIN: So
what happened?
JAMES CRACKNELL: Yeah.
No, thanks.
That's a good snapshot of--
BEVERLEY TURNER: It's
your CV, right?
JAMES CRACKNELL: Yeah.
No.
I think retiring from
sport is difficult.
You only need to look at the
last five or six weeks as to
what's happened to people you
think should be happy who came
back for different reasons.
Take Michael Schumacher.
Why would someone come back
who'd won that match.
And then not come back in the
team that could have given him
the opportunity to win.
You take Ricky Hatton who
struggled after retiring and
didn't go out in the way he
wanted after fighting many
[INAUDIBLE].
You take Freddie Flintoff.
He didn't retire on his own
terms, because of injury and
not looking after it.
So he went back into
the boxing ring.
I think it is really hard to
retire and come to terms with
the decision.
And a psychologist told me that
it takes you two years to
genuinely retire and not look
at sport in the same way and
think, oh, I wish
I could do that.
And so I managed to not compete
for a year after the
Athens Olympics.
And you get invited to
parties for about a
week after the Olympics.
And then the invites go rrr.
And I was at all these parties
when the slightly camp bloke
from the TV comes up--
I hope you're not watching
Google, Ben--
and said, I'm going
to do a rowing
race across the Atlantic.
Do you want to do it with me?
I was like, can you row?
He goes, no.
I go, no, no, no.
And then I realized that I
didn't have a goal for the
first time in a long time.
And I thought about
it for a month.
And I thought, actually, it
might be a really good
distraction.
And it gave me time to think
about whether I wanted to row
in the Beijing Olympics
or not.
MATT BRITTIN: So at that stage,
you were still thinking
you probably would?
JAMES CRACKNELL: I was thinking
because of that run
up to Athens with a whole
lot of injuries.
And I went from a two-man boat
to the four-man boat.
And as far as our first
race as the four-man
boat, was the Olympics.
So I just wasn't ready to commit
to another four years
straightaway.
And that's the real difference,
is this.
MATT BRITTIN: By then, you
were already a couple.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Yeah.
JAMES CRACKNELL: We had a
10-month-old little boy at
that stage.
MATT BRITTIN: So you've seen
James go through the Olympics.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Yeah.
MATT BRITTIN: And win the
second medal, yeah.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Yeah.
I think the word you're looking
for is "supported"
James going through
the Olympics.
[LAUGHS]
MATT BRITTIN: Supported.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Not seen.
MATT BRITTIN: OK.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Yeah.
MATT BRITTIN: Tell us
more about that.
[LAUGHTER]
BEVERLEY TURNER: You know it's
hard being the partner of an
Olympian is really hard.
I watched London 2012.
And you see Mo Farah's wife
there on the sidelines.
When he's won, she'll just
look so wonderful.
And I just thought, oh,
you've been through
hell, haven't you?
Because the big sacrifices that
the Olympians inevitably
have to make, it's everything.
It's the complete focus
of their life.
And so, as the partner, you're
standing going, come on.
When is this Olympic final?
Let's get it over with.
And then we can get
on with our life.
And James obviously won
the gold medal.
That was all marvelous.
And then he said he was going to
row across the Atlantic for
two months, which was not what
I had in mind at all.
I was thinking maybe a holiday
or spend some time as a
family, because we'd
actually spent very
little time as a family.
So I was really hacked
off about it.
And Ben Fogle's wife was
very supportive.
JAMES CRACKNELL: I didn't
enjoy it, if that's any
consolation to you.
BEVERLEY TURNER: No.
You hated it.
Actually, I liked the fact
that you didn't enjoy it.
[LAUGHTER]
BEVERLEY TURNER: But when he
came back, it was actually the
best thing he'd ever done.
MATT BRITTIN: It was?
BEVERLEY TURNER: It was the
best thing he ever did.
Yeah, it was.
MATT BRITTIN: Why was that?
Why do you say that?
BEVERLEY TURNER: Because, as
James was saying, as a
sportsman, I think, when you're
retiring or you're
trying to work out what you're
going to do with the rest of
your life, when you're in your
30s, it's such an identity
crisis because what do you do?
How do you go from living such
an exciting and demanding and
challenging day to day
existence and all the
adulation that comes with
winning an Olympic gold medal?
JAMES CRACKNELL: Matt
rowed, by the way.
So you realize that's not
how it is at all.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES CRACKNELL: Yeah.
The adulation really
did not happen.
MATT BRITTIN: I certainly don't
remember any adulation.
JAMES CRACKNELL: No.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT BRITTIN: So not necessarily
quite so
successful.
BEVERLEY TURNER: But you know
James can't sit still long
enough to do a job like
you do, Matt.
That's the difference, is he
needed to be on the move.
And so actually, to have this
trip, which made him decide
what he wants to do.
And he wanted to make his
hobbies into his job, which is
to do this kind of thing.
MATT BRITTIN: So he found this
by chance, thanks to a chance
conversation at a party.
BEVERLEY TURNER:
Yeah, with Ben.
Yeah.
And then, obviously, raced to
the South Pole and did all the
various marathons and
stuff like that.
MATT BRITTIN: It seems to
be there's an important
difference between being a
supportive wife watching
somebody trying to win an
Olympic gold medal and waiting
for him to phone in that he's
crossed the Atlantic in a
rowing boat.
And that is what's the worst
that can go wrong in a rowing
race is, well, you might
not get the medal.
I know about that.
It's not quite the same
thing as the danger
that is being at sea.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Yeah,
it's funny though.
MATT BRITTIN: And since then,
he's done lots of dangerous
things, right?
BEVERLEY TURNER: Yeah, but
they're not really dangerous.
He's not a base jumper.
[LAUGHTER]
BEVERLEY TURNER: I know it
sounds a bit crazy, but I'm
such a safety girl.
I'm a seat belt and a condom
type of girl, and
not at the same time.
JAMES CRACKNELL: We have
three children.
That's not [INAUDIBLE].
BEVERLEY TURNER: Yeah.
Clearly not.
MATT BRITTIN: Not always.
BEVERLEY TURNER: But
I've always been--
JAMES CRACKNELL: But
statistically unlucky.
BEVERLEY TURNER: From being very
young, I've always been
about self-preservation
and safety.
MATT BRITTIN: I think that
should be the title
of your next book.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT BRITTIN: "Seat Belts
and Condoms."
BEVERLEY TURNER: "Seat Belt
and a Condom." And so I'm
quite careful.
And so, for me--
JAMES CRACKNELL: Well,
not really.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT BRITTIN: Keep going.
Keep going.
We're with you.
BEVERLEY TURNER: So anyway, I
actually always worried more
when he went on his bicycle.
MATT BRITTIN: Right.
BEVERLEY TURNER: For
me, that was the
most frightening thing.
MATT BRITTIN: Just
in around London.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Just
going out of
the door on his bicycle.
Or he used to ride
a motor bike.
I had much more of a problem
with that than I did--
because with all of these
trips there are safety
measures in place.
And the Atlantic row
was probably,
actually, the most dangerous.
JAMES CRACKNELL: Yeah.
I think the things that I've
done, they may be remote, but
it's going to be your mistake
that is a problem.
The Atlantic is slightly
different, because there are
tankers that are
on auto-pilot.
And you need to make sure
you're aware of it.
BEVERLEY TURNER: [LAUGHS]
Now you tell me.
JAMES CRACKNELL: But the South
Pole, it's generally a
deserted environment.
It's your decision in
the environment.
Whereas, on a public highway,
you are liable to other people
making mistakes.
You can't control the people's
behavior, if that be on a
street in London or a train
or a plane or on a road.
Whereas, in the South
Pole, there may be
a knocked off penguin.
But it's, pretty much,
everything else is going to be
down to you.
MATT BRITTIN: Yes.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Yeah.
MATT BRITTIN: So you did
the rowing across
the Atlantic thing.
You did the South
Pole expedition.
I think quite a few people have
seen that on the TV, the
documentary that you made there
which, again, looked
like very, very tough
conditions.
JAMES CRACKNELL: Tough
conditions, yeah.
It was tough in that the
temperature was not very nice.
It's not an easy place to go,
because everything takes so
much longer to do.
MATT BRITTIN: In the TV show,
it looked like you also--
the difference between James
Cracknell as a somewhat
extreme Olympian and the other
more regular guys in the team,
it certainly looked like
you were pushing
it harder than the--
I've read the book.
And I think your view is that
you were portrayed in a little
bit of an extreme way in that,
in terms of [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES CRACKNELL: Yeah.
I think, in terms of--
you know as well.
In a sports environment, you
end up racing a boat and
training with eight people.
And your thoughts and opinions
may be here and here, either
end of the scale.
But there's always the target,
which is to win.
And so that brings you
back together.
Whereas, if you're with people
whose end goal is not the
same-- well, it's to get there,
but not get there as
quick as you can--
there isn't that same
focal point to
bring you back together.
So it was very useful for me
in terms of learning how to
work with other people.
But there's a mentality of a
elite or full-time sportsman
that is different from
some people.
You think, well, Bev, you've
come to a few Olympic
receptions that we've been to.
And I didn't take this quite as
positively as she meant it.
Well, I hope she
meant it to be.
She was like, show me a room of
Olympic gold medalists, and
I'll show you a room full
of insecure people.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES CRACKNELL:
I was like, hm.
BEVERLEY TURNER: It's true
though, isn't it?
MATT BRITTIN: It's true.
BEVERLEY TURNER: It
is true, isn't it?
You know that.
JAMES CRACKNELL: Sort of
judging you basically--
[LAUGHTER]
BEVERLEY TURNER: Come on.
All you Olympic gold medalists,
it's true.
I think that there has to be
something about wanting to
prove yourself, prove
yourself.
But thank goodness.
I did also say--
JAMES CRACKNELL: Or
being judged by
something other than yourself.
MATT BRITTIN: Yep.
JAMES CRACKNELL: Fulfillment
and belief in yourself.
MATT BRITTIN: I can see that.
JAMES CRACKNELL: And judging
by a kind of
target of other people.
BEVERLEY TURNER: It's an
exterior kind of validation.
MATT BRITTIN: Well, I guess
that's your thing about
finding your next thing which
is going to validate you or
give you the goal, et cetera.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Exactly.
JAMES CRACKNELL: Which I don't
think is a particularly
mentally healthy place to be.
I think the guys I went with,
Ben and Ed, they found self
fulfillment in a different
way, rather than it being
something extra that
is outside.
MATT BRITTIN: Yeah.
Just getting there would
be fine for them.
JAMES CRACKNELL: Yeah.
MATT BRITTIN: But you wanted
to get there and beat the
Norweigians in your
first attempt.
JAMES CRACKNELL: Yeah.
BEVERLEY TURNER: There
won't be a second.
JAMES CRACKNELL: Be rewarded.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES CRACKNELL: But then
we'd also said--
I'd taken the philosophy in
training that, with me and
with them, if we make it as
uncomfortable and as hard as
possible here, which I'll make
it worse here than it is
there, no day there is going
to feel that bad.
Whereas, if you don't train that
hard before we go, it's
going to be really horrible.
If it's nasty, we're just
going to go, oh!
And we're miles from anywhere.
MATT BRITTIN: So just on that
point, I cycled in this
morning through Richmond Park.
And having read your book, I
had in my mind the image of
you climbing over the gate at
Richmond Park with a bicycle
tire, which you were then going
to drag around the park
in training for this event
during the night so not to
disturb the kids.
JAMES CRACKNELL: Yeah.
I have to say that--
MATT BRITTIN: That's what
you were doing.
JAMES CRACKNELL: Yeah.
Yeah, because it's very hard to
recreate pulling a sledge.
So you basically drag a tire.
Not a bicycle tire.
It's more like a lorry tire.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES CRACKNELL: But the reason
I had to climb the
fence is because every year they
have a month where they
cull the deer in
Richmond Park.
It's like eight miles
around the outside.
And so it's generally
open 24 hours a day
to people on bikes.
So there's lots of weirdos
cycling around at midnight.
But then they have cars.
And they obviously
have proper jobs.
And they can't get out
during the day.
And so they lock
the gates then.
So I had to climb over, drag
this bloody tire over the
fence, and then walk around.
And every so often, you'd
hear a crack of a rifle.
[INAUDIBLE]
So it's real lucky I didn't
go in my antler hat.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES CRACKNELL: So
I was all right.
And at that stage, you
were pregnant with
Ki Ki, weren't you?
But we had a family and
everything else.
It was more beneficial to us, as
a family, if I trained when
the others were asleep.
So do admit I was a bit of a
weirdo going around the park
in the middle of the night
pulling a tire.
BEVERLEY TURNER: It's true.
I was just going to say, people
said, obviously, all
that training, he must
be very selfish.
And actually, he
did used to be.
But I think what James has
managed to do quite well-- and
I think anybody who works and
has long hours-- is it's so
hard to find any kind of time
to put exercise or anything
into your day.
I don't really get to do any.
But there was one night when
he was training for the
Marathon des Sables, which was
another event that is on one
of the DVDs, on the
book, actually.
And we'd been to a black
tie event in London.
And I was actually driving.
And we came out.
And James gets out of his suit
and puts on his running gear.
And it's midnight.
And I said, what
are you doing?
He said, well, I'm going
to run home.
[LAUGHTER]
BEVERLEY TURNER: So I drove
down the A4 back out to
Chiswick where we lived from
the center of town.
And James ran home.
And I think he pretty much
beat me there, I think.
MATT BRITTIN: That's
pretty normal.
I used to do that all the
time when I was pissed.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT BRITTIN: You just glossed
over another thing that--
I want to move forward a bit.
But just briefly, Marathon des
Sables, James, how far do you
run in that?
JAMES CRACKNELL: It's a
series of marathons
in the Sahara desert.
There's a marathon every day
for six, seven days.
And then, one day, they decide
you do two marathons.
But you carry all the food
and everything you
need for the week.
MATT BRITTIN: It's literally
over sand dunes, isn't it?
JAMES CRACKNELL: Yeah, sand
dunes and rocky [INAUDIBLE]
and that sort of just being in
a tent with no [INAUDIBLE].
MATT BRITTIN: We're sort of
throwing around Olympic gold
medals and gold medalists as
though they were two a penny.
But I think one of the
remarkable things is it's
quite hard to get an
Olympic gold medal.
We're taking them for
granted here now.
But also, you're the fastest
Brit, I think, ever to have
finished a Marathon
des Sables.
JAMES CRACKNELL: Yeah.
No, I was--
MATT BRITTIN: It's pretty
impressive for
a guy of 100 kilos.
JAMES CRACKNELL: I was
really thinking.
And I was really chuffed,
because I decided to do it.
Well, there's two [INAUDIBLE].
The first one, I was
at the South Pole.
And we'd had the thing about
being honest with each other.
As I said, I was training
very hard for it.
And we had also said we'd
be really honest.
So if we were struggling, it
didn't matter what weight we
all took, as long as the three
of us and all our kit got to
the South Pole.
So some day, if you were feeling
good, you'd take more.
If you weren't, you wouldn't
feel bad about giving someone
else some weight.
And over the first week, the
others were struggling a bit.
So I took some of
their weight.
And then I started
to struggle.
And I didn't say.
And so I got really
nasty blisters and
pneumonia on my left lung.
And that really slowed
us down.
And I was at South Pole and
feeling really not very good.
And it's also weird
I was at the South
Pole, for various reasons.
And this one comes into the
tent and he goes, oh, you
think those blisters are
bad, you should do the
Marathon des Sables.
I don't know why, at that
point, I thought
that'd be a good idea.
[LAUGHTER]
BEVERLEY TURNER: He
was like, yeah.
That's a really great idea.
JAMES CRACKNELL: I know.
I'll go running in the sand.
But the second reason was,
I wanted to show, in a
competitive environment, I could
make the right decision
at the right time.
So stopping in the middle of a
race was quite alien to me.
But two minutes, five minutes
there would save an hour
further down the line.
And for me, making that decision
then was something I
wouldn't have done
in the past.
And I think that's why I did do
better there is that I made
the right decision at
the right time.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Yeah.
And actually, it's an
amazing program.
It's my favorite film of
all of James' films.
It's just a fantastic filmmaker
called David Harrison.
And it's just the most brilliant
documentary.
And like you say, it
was Easter time.
And I was with the kids
down in Devon.
And just got the odd phone
call to say, he's alive.
He's fine.
And then, when he called
and said, oh, well,
actually, I came 12th.
And how many people were--
JAMES CRACKNELL: There was
1,000 did it that day.
BEVERLEY TURNER:
1,000 runners.
JAMES CRACKNELL: That year.
BEVERLEY TURNER: He came 12th.
Oh.
Well done!
JAMES CRACKNELL: The
guy who won it--
BEVERLEY TURNER: The
fastest ever Brit.
The fastest ever Brit, which is
amazing because they're all
tiny little gazelles,
aren't they?
JAMES CRACKNELL: Well, the guy
who came over and we did some
sort of heat testing for the
documentary before we went.
And the guy who had won it the
previous year came over, a
Moroccan guy called Mohammad.
And we just ran in a 50 degree
chamber on the treadmill.
And he got off the plane from
Morocco, gets to the chamber.
And the first thing they do is
give him a thermometer to
stick up his bum,
because his core
temperature could be monitored.
And if health and safety
is breached, you
could be dragged out.
And so he wasn't delighted about
that the first thing.
This is not a very
good country.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES CRACKNELL: But we ran
for an hour in 50 degrees.
And I lost four kilos.
And he lost half a kilo.
And that's just how
attuned to--
BEVERLEY TURNER: He was
up to here on you.
JAMES CRACKNELL: He
was not very big.
And you get the same amount
of water every day.
So they give you water, but
you carry your own food.
So he was like showering
in it.
Whereas, I was every drop
was a prisoner.
MATT BRITTIN: So I'd like to
move it on to what happened at
your accident and
then after it.
But just before we do that, so
all of the stuff you've done
up to the point of the race
across America, what would you
say was the hardest?
And what would you say
you're most proud of?
JAMES CRACKNELL: I think I was
most proud of the Marathon des
Sable in terms of making
the right decision
at the right time.
And having learned from the
others, and showing that, in a
competitive environment, I
could separate the two.
In terms of the hardest, I
think, for the first week of
the Atlantic I found really hard
because everything I'd
done previously, as you said
at the start, is what's the
worst that could happen?
Well, you might lose the race.
But even in the start of the
Athens Olympics, I always make
sure we're straight
in the lane.
And I could see the finish tower
2,000 meters away, which
is our race distance.
And as much as you should be
thinking positive things, I
thought, cor, that's
a long way.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES CRACKNELL: But the
difference between that and,
say, the Atlantic is that it's
the first race I've done where
you couldn't see the
finish line.
And even after you row a week,
we're still 3,000 miles away.
And that was getting my head
around a target that
seemed so far away.
And even if you break it down
into chunks that are big
enough to take something out of
the overall distance, but
small enough to get your head
around was really hard.
And it took me a week
to get myself into
the right space to--
MATT BRITTIN: So
mentally ready?
JAMES CRACKNELL: Yeah.
BEVERLEY TURNER: He
kept ringing and
crying on the phone.
JAMES CRACKNELL: Yeah.
It was that way.
Not a very good time.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Ben
Fogle cried a lot.
Ben Fogle does cry a lot
most of the time.
MATT BRITTIN: Right.
Yeah.
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
BEVERLEY TURNER: But James
doesn't tend to
cry an awful lot.
MATT BRITTIN: Oh, yeah.
BEVERLEY TURNER: He'd ring on
this big satellite phone,
wouldn't you?
[LAUGHS]
MATT BRITTIN: But you
sound like you
weren't very bothered.
BEVERLEY TURNER: No, I wasn't.
I was just like, yeah,
suck it up.
You chose to be here.
The children are--
Cory's fine, thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES CRACKNELL: The ability
to be positive in any
situation is something that
I've learned as well.
MATT BRITTIN: I see how
the supportive wife--
BEVERLEY TURNER: [LAUGHS]
Yeah.
MATT BRITTIN: But let's go to
a different phone call.
So you got a phone call
telling you that
James was in hospital.
And what happened then?
What happens next?
BEVERLEY TURNER: Well, that was,
as you said, I was back
in Vegas having a lovely time.
And I got a call at 6, 7 o'clock
in the morning, I
think it was, just to say, oh,
don't go back to London.
You need to get to Phoenix.
James has been hit by a truck.
And at that point, I didn't know
what the prognosis was
going to be.
I didn't know anything.
In fact, one of the trainers
on that film was one of the
guys who rung me.
And I was on my own in Vegas.
I think human beings are much
better at coping, probably,
than we imagine we're
going to be.
And I think women, particularly,
are good.
And I think we kind of go into
coping strategy, coping mode.
And I got to Phoenix and booked
a flight and got there.
And I didn't know when I got off
that flight whether he was
going to be alive or dead
by the time I got off.
I didn't know much
about the injury.
I knew that he'd been
helicoptered from
the side of the road.
It obviously was very serious,
because they were saying you
have to get here.
And they would never do that.
The team would never say, Bev,
you need to come out.
Because, as you can see, he has
a lot of people that look
after him on those
kind of trips.
And I was met in the hospital
by a really
lovely American doctor.
And it was all kind
of very odd.
It was sort of like it's so
familiar to you because of
"ER" and American television
medical dramas that
it's sort of odd.
But it's strangely familiar
in the same way.
And obviously, he was heavily,
heavily sedated and had a
collar that was--
and to all intents and purposes
he looked fine.
He looked quite well, because
he was fairly well.
He was very well, except that
he'd had a very bad--
JAMES CRACKNELL: Well?
BEVERLEY TURNER: Well, you
weren't very well.
But I mean, at that time in
your life, you were--
MATT BRITTIN: But physically,
he was in good condition.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Physically,
you were in great shape is
what I mean.
And so he had a tan and
he'd been running.
And it sounds ridiculous
doesn't it?
But it was the perfect
introduction, actually, to
brain injury as the hidden
illness because, amazingly, to
be hit from, we think, about 70
mile an hour petrol tanker,
the wing mirror to the back of
the head, he didn't have a
broken bone in his body.
He should have had
a broken neck.
He should have never been able
to walk again, really.
And he was so lucky.
Bike helmet, that wasn't luck.
But he sustained a frontal lobe
injury, what they call a
contrecoup.
So it's like the brain swings
forward in the head.
So even though the impact is to
the back, the injury is to
the front of the brain.
And James' parents came
out not long after.
My mom came out.
And then James started
to come round.
JAMES CRACKNELL: Don't look
at me for answers.
BEVERLEY TURNER: I know.
You have no idea do you?
You can't help me out
at all can you?
And they'd established fairly
quickly that he
was going to live.
And then they had said, oh, you
know, we need to watch to
see if we need to do brain
surgery, if the brain
continues to swell.
I mean, in some ways, it was
great that we were in America,
because the care there for that
kind of injury-- well,
for anything in that
kind of setting--
is the best in the world.
And so we had a month in
Arizona, in Phoenix.
MATT BRITTIN: And how long was
it before James came round and
was able to converse with you?
BEVERLEY TURNER: Well, I
can't really remember.
It was a few days
of touch and go.
And the thing is they couldn't
say, he will be fine.
They just can't say that about
the brain, because it will
affect people in
different ways.
And in fact, the severity of
James' injury, there's just no
way that he should be able
to stand here and
talk to you like this.
It's incredible.
And then he did start to come
round and was clearly mad as a
box of frogs.
MATT BRITTIN: He was incredibly
posh, you said.
BEVERLEY TURNER: He was
incredibly posh.
He started talking
in this accent.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT BRITTIN: That's too long
with Mattie Pinsent, though.
JAMES CRACKNELL: [LAUGHS]
Yeah.
BEVERLEY TURNER: And Ben
Fogle, isn't it?
MATT BRITTIN: Yeah
and [INAUDIBLE].
BEVERLEY TURNER: And just sort
of asking to use the water
closet and talking about,
[WITH ACCENT]
"Oh, when I was in the household
cavalry, there was
this one occasion--" And
it was freaky, trippy.
Like you would think it was past
life stuff, seriously,
the craziness that was coming
out of his mouth.
And as much as we laugh
about it now, we
laughed about it then.
His parents and I were just
doubled over some days in the
hospital, because it was
just ridiculous.
But I think, again, it's kind
of that coping strategy.
And I think mother nature's
very clever.
You need something to drag you
through those dark times when
it seems so desperate.
And he was bloody hilarious.
[LAUGHS]
MATT BRITTIN: Right.
So you were just pleased he was
there and being funny and
coming out of it.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Yeah.
It was a bit like that.
And I found out I was pregnant
nine days after the accident.
MATT BRITTIN: Right.
So he's lying there and--
BEVERLEY TURNER: With
child number three.
MATT BRITTIN: Number three child
inside you, and he's in
this situation.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Yeah, that was
a low point, to be honest.
Well, it was and it wasn't.
In some way it was great.
But in another way, it was
oh god, how am I going
to deal with this?
Because we weren't quite sure
what the care was going to be,
how we were going to manage
the recovery.
And really, throwing
a new baby into all
that as well was difficult.
MATT BRITTIN: And you took him
home after a month or so.
Is that right?
JAMES CRACKNELL: Well, I think
what would have been weirder
for you was--
because the staff see a
traumatic brain injury victim
so regularly, that they're
sort of normal.
It's like, oh, they always do
that, as though you're some
part of a new civilization.
So when I was sitting up and
able to eat, they bring you a
starter, a main course
and desert.
And I just mixed it all
together, because you're not
really sure what you're doing.
And I still have no sense
of taste or smell.
So it doesn't really
matter what.
It could be anything.
And so Bev says that she and
my mom and dad looked at me
just pouring my custard
on top of my--
BEVERLEY TURNER: Chicken.
JAMES CRACKNELL: Pasta or
on top of my burger.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES CRACKNELL: And the staff,
oh, they always do
that, as though I've suddenly
joined this group.
MATT BRITTIN: This
class of people.
JAMES CRACKNELL: And at
that must have been
really hard for them.
And then, on top of that, I then
insult the nurse, which I
didn't think was an insult.
BEVERLEY TURNER: No, you
insulted everybody.
JAMES CRACKNELL: No, I didn't
think it was an insult.
It's that I asked her if she was
a running back, which is
an American football position,
because apparently, she had a
very, very powerfully
built backside.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES CRACKNELL: Slash large.
MATT BRITTIN: Right.
Perfectly fair question.
BEVERLEY TURNER: He asked her if
she'd put some time in with
the Pittsburgh Steelers.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES CRACKNELL: But
that's because--
if you'd known anything about
American football, I did watch
a bit of it--
there's this guy, a running
back, which is like--
MATT BRITTIN: Don't
try and justify.
BEVERLEY TURNER: No, no, no.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES CRACKNELL: It's
a position of--
so if you take in Rugby--
BEVERLEY TURNER: There's
no logic to it.
JAMES CRACKNELL: It's
the center.
So the guy runs anywhere.
What [INAUDIBLE] used to
play and [INAUDIBLE].
And there's this guy with the
Pittsburgh Steelers who must
have won the Super Bowl a
couple of years before.
And he had a very powerful
backside.
He was called the Fun Bus.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Yeah, I
think you called her
the Fun Bus, actually.
JAMES CRACKNELL: And I might
have actually called her the
Fun Bus by mistake.
BEVERLEY TURNER: I
think you did.
And then he rang me--
JAMES CRACKNELL: I can't
remember exactly.
BEVERLEY TURNER: --in the
hotel one morning.
And we had to confiscate
phones and change email
passwords and everything,
because he was trying to--
this is a couple of weeks in--
he was trying to communicate
with the outside world and
still thought he was fine.
There was no problem.
Everybody else had gone mad.
He was completely normal.
And he rang me at the hotel and
said, you've got to bring
me some extra kit
to the hospital.
And I said, right.
OK, what do you mean?
And I'm thinking where
is this going?
And he said, I need
some running kit.
And I need some extra kit,
orange preferably.
And I said, why?
And he said, because I'm
representing Holland in the
synchronized pooing
championships.
[LAUGHTER]
BEVERLEY TURNER: Seriously.
Seriously.
MATT BRITTIN: I can't--
I don't know.
JAMES CRACKNELL: It's OK.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Our
nine-year-old loves that story.
MATT BRITTIN: Yeah.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Our
nine-year-old boy thinks that
is brilliant.
MATT BRITTIN: I think
you could organize
an event to do that.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Yeah.
JAMES CRACKNELL: Again,
that's one I'll take
Matthew Pinsent in.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT BRITTIN: OK.
JAMES CRACKNELL: He's
a big fellow.
He's got skills in that area.
MATT BRITTIN: I guess, for all
of us sitting here, people who
didn't know you previous to the
accident, you look like a
very happy pair who
get on well and
known each other forever.
But Bev, he's quite different
from before.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Yeah.
MATT BRITTIN: Well,
to some extent.
He's obviously not as different
as when he was posh
and pooing for Netherlands.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT BRITTIN: He's still
a bit different.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Yeah, he is.
He is different.
I mean, we're probably both
different, because the
experience has changed us.
But yeah, it's been a very long,
slow, difficult road of
two and a half years
of recovery.
But the frontal lobe controls
your personality.
And it's how you understand
emotion.
It's how you communicate.
James won't remember any of the
time of coming home from
the hospital.
But he was very angry.
And it's typical, unfortunately,
of how we look
after people in this country
who have a brain injury.
We send them home.
They go home to families
with small children.
And they are a completely
different person.
They bear no resemblance to
the kind and considerate--
MATT BRITTIN: And you're talking
in the general now.
BEVERLEY TURNER: In
the general term.
But it applies specifically
to James, yeah.
And actually, what it does,
when I say it bears no
resemblance, the way the
neurologist described it to me
is he will be more of himself.
So people with frontal lobe
injury often become a kind of
evil caricature of themselves.
So if you can imagine your
partner's worst traits and
magnify them by 100 and take
away all the good stuff,
that's kind of what
you're left with.
He's not like that now.
I should just point this is
two and a half years.
MATT BRITTIN: That what it was
like when he landed back at
home after a month.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Yeah.
Yeah.
And it was like that
for a long time.
But I think, actually, the drive
that we were talking
about at the beginning of the
chat, the whole wanting to be
as good as he could possibly
be, James, just in very
typical fashion, has
applied that
mentality to his recovery.
And I think the exercise
actually helped.
He was in the gym every day.
And he has been since the
day of the accident.
That getting physically well,
trying to be fit and healthy,
I think, has put him
in great stead.
MATT BRITTIN: But in this case,
James, you're going to
the South Pole.
It's clear how you're going
to train for that.
You're going to try and win an
Olympic gold medal in rowing.
It's clear how you're going
to train for that.
In this context you've said,
I'm trying to get back to
being James Cracknell.
There's no roadmap for that.
So what have you done to try
to recover what you want to
recover of yourself?
JAMES CRACKNELL: Yeah,
you're right.
That's the one thing.
There is no objective scale to
work onto, it's a little bit
subjective.
And people often don't
say what they think.
They may say something,
after they've seen
you, to someone else.
But they never really say it to
your face, whether you're
different or you get angry
slightly differently.
It's like, I guess, doing
something productive, except I
wasn't able to go back to, say,
a writer of a newspaper
or get back to other work.
So I would--
getting fit was something
I could control.
And then I'd have to see
the neurologist,
neuropsychologist, occupational
therapist.
And you spend a lot of time
talking about yourself and
about issues that you've
probably avoided.
And we didn't really
see a sports
psychologist when I was competing.
We were, luckily, in a
team, so we'd talk to
each other about it.
And so it was something
that was alien to me.
It was taking me time to get
to a position where I
understood that this is an area
that I had to work on as
well and to really buy
into it to progress.
Because it's not fair on Bev
or the kids, if you're
reacting differently or quicker
to a certain situation
than you would have
in the past.
Because Bev's had a different
husband for the last three
years than she had for
the first seven.
And my little boys had a
different dad for the last
three years than they had for
the first six, because I get
angry and non-consistent.
I think that all kids
especially want is a
consistency in their life.
And they find behaving like his
age one minute and then
like a really grumpy grand dad
the next minute is hard in
terms of being fixated on
certain things like table
manners, of which I'm not
the best at anyway.
But if it just means eating a
meal, it's not fun for him to
be with me.
And that's been the hardest.
BEVERLEY TURNER: They're
running into hooks.
MATT BRITTIN: Yeah, literally.
BEVERLEY TURNER: I mean, on a
good day I go, well, who wants
to be married to the same
man for 10 years anyway?
Not me, [LAUGHS]
you know?
I was ready for a new one.
But then, on a hard day, it
can be quite difficult.
MATT BRITTIN: Yeah.
And James, was there a period
during which you had to accept
that you were different?
Because it sounds like you felt
everything you were doing
was normal.
Was there a period during which
you realized that things
had changed?
You said people weren't treating
you differently.
But you were conscious they
were saying something
afterwards.
JAMES CRACKNELL: Yeah.
I'd say yes, in a number of
different ways, because the
Olympics were here.
And I got back to working.
And I worked for a local
company that
organized the Olympics.
And so I had to do this speech
to one of the Olympic sponsors
on behalf of [INAUDIBLE].
And I'm in a briefing before.
An afterwards, talking about
some other things, and he
said, yeah-- you hit
every one of them--
that was very good, especially
for a guy with a brain injury.
And then right since the
accident I haven't wanted to
be judged on any other scale.
So it was a bad thing to use
as, that's very good,
especially for someone
who's had cancer.
Go off and pump yourself
with drugs.
The attitude is you don't be
judged along any other
[INAUDIBLE].
And that's been one of the
things that has been hard.
And then also, with our third
child, we needed to get a
bigger house.
And then we found out we had
to try to get a mortgage.
And they're like, well, we can't
guarantee your earnings
over the next 10 years.
And I'm saying, well, who can?
But it's not because of that.
It's because of, bang,
a brain injury.
This, whether it's practical,
emotional or being judged, is
very difficult.
And the one thing that I've
found, from the medical, to
friends, to colleagues, is that
people are very quick to
impose a ceiling on you and
think, well, you won't be able
to do that.
So if people lower their
expectation of you and then
that affects your expectation
of yourself.
And if you only aspire to that
ceiling, that's the only place
you're going to reach.
And also I think there are too
many dream takers there,
whether it be you're in a pub
with mates and you're going to
ask that girl out.
And they go, she's out
of your league.
You'll never bother.
When I said, I want to go to the
Olympics, you went, oh, a
lot of people have
tried to do that.
And so, if you listen to those
things, you're never going to
do it, whether it's starting a
business and someone goes,
most fail in three years.
And all those things chip
away at someone's
belief to go for it.
And then that's really
happened over the
last couple of years.
And I just think it's very hard
for someone who maybe
wasn't so--
I say stubborn as though
it's a bad thing.
MATT BRITTIN: Stubborn's
a good word.
JAMES CRACKNELL: Yeah.
Someone as stubborn as me, they
think, well, I'm going to
prove you wrong or justify
what you say.
Rather than just treat me
as a statistic, you
need to justify that.
And I think it's really
important for anyone who's not
just suffered a brain injury,
but who's going through a
tough time or wants to achieve
something else or wants to
move their life on not to feel
they're being imposed on by
other people.
And then the limits are being
set by something from outside.
MATT BRITTIN: But at home, it
sounds like people aren't
imposing that on you.
They're expecting you to--
JAMES CRACKNELL: Well,
I hope so.
And it's been difficult.
MATT BRITTIN: How do you
do supporting role now?
BEVERLEY TURNER: The biggest
thing is the nag of trying to
get him to rest a bit
and slow down.
That's probably one of
the hardest things.
And then I don't know.
Now I might have to kind of
let him get on with it.
I spent a lot of time,
especially when he first came
out of the hospital and he
wanted to go and enter the
Great North Run in
a wheelchair--
[LAUGHS]
MATT BRITTIN: So you spent some
time saying no at that.
BEVERLEY TURNER:
Yeah, exactly.
And so I had to do quite a
lot of stepping in at the
beginning and just going no,
no, and dealing with his
agents and just trying to--
just being the jailer and
just saying, I know
he seems OK to you.
But trust me, he's not.
And so I had a lot of
time doing that.
JAMES CRACKNELL: So that's
interesting, because you
wanted to get me into
a wheelchair
when we were in America.
BEVERLEY TURNER: What
do you mean?
JAMES CRACKNELL: When we
flew back from America.
BEVERLEY TURNER: [LAUGHS]
JAMES CRACKNELL: See?
BEVERLEY TURNER: Yeah.
JAMES CRACKNELL: Getting out
of the hospital, we're
checking into the airport.
So I had the type of doctor
with me on the plane.
And checking in, the lady said,
can you use a wheelchair
to take to the plane?
BEVERLEY TURNER: Of course, he
was just like [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES CRACKNELL: I
was, I can walk.
I'm fine.
And Bev goes, take
the wheelchair.
We'll get to the front
of the queue.
[LAUGHTER]
BEVERLEY TURNER: Get in
the bloody wheelchair.
There's a massive queue.
JAMES CRACKNELL: So in the end,
the compromise was Bev
put the bags in the wheelchair
and pushed to the
front of the queue.
BEVERLEY TURNER: I said,
I'm pregnant.
Do you mind?
JAMES CRACKNELL: So apologies
to anyone that was there.
BEVERLEY TURNER: I was going
to sit in the wheelchair.
But yeah.
It's not that pride and
that stubbornness,
which can be difficult.
But actually, like I say, it's
probably why his recovery has
been so good is because of that
mentality of saying, I
will prove you wrong.
MATT BRITTIN: So there's
lots more the book.
And it's not actually a book,
really, about the sporting
endeavors at all.
It's about rebuilding
a person, I guess.
BEVERLEY TURNER: I think so.
There's quite a bit, I guess,
of some rowing stuff,
childhood stuff to just kind
of give you a sense of who
James was before the accident.
JAMES CRACKNELL: I like the way
you build up the rowing
and the childhood
into just stuff.
[LAUGHTER]
BEVERLEY TURNER: But actually,
we couldn't
not write this book.
We have been through--
MATT BRITTIN: What drove
you to write it then?
Why did you write it?
BEVERLEY TURNER: Because there
is so little out there for
people with a brain injury in
terms of how you support
families and how you
cope with it.
There was one little book that
I was given by a physio in
hospital in Phoenix called,
"Where is the Mango
Princess?," which is an amazing
book written by the
wife of a brain injured man who
was a journalist as well.
Her book is amazing.
And she's actually,
sadly, died.
But inspired by that largely,
we thought, well,
we've got to do it.
James has been asked
to do his biography
so many times before.
And he's always just gone, I'm
not ready to do anything.
I'm not doing anything.
And actually, we just thought,
well, there's
a reason for this.
We can't not write it.
And in fact, the response we've
had from families who
have had similar injuries
has been immense.
MATT BRITTIN: Well, I know we
were saying over lunch that
[INAUDIBLE] get to know you
James as well, but his name
came up during the summer.
And he said, oh, yeah.
He made that great video about
wearing a bike helmet.
And so now, actually, people are
being encouraged to wear a
bike helmets as a result.
But I want to give people,
while there's a couple of
minutes left, any chance for
anybody to ask questions of
this amazing couple.
Now is your opportunity.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Oh, my god.
Oh.
MATT BRITTIN: Nobody?
JAMES CRACKNELL: Yep.
MATT BRITTIN: Yeah.
Oh.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thank you, very much,
first of all, for coming
in and sharing your story.
Very inspiring.
I have a question for
both of you, really.
You talked about your
kids before.
And I guess, if one day one of
them comes up to you and says
I want to become a professional
athlete, what
would your response be?
What would your advice be, given
all you went through?
JAMES CRACKNELL: Well, I guess
it would depend how old he was
or she was.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Yeah.
Did you see that?
A little bit sexist.
MATT BRITTIN: Yes.
I saw that.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT BRITTIN: He's going
to be a swimmer.
JAMES CRACKNELL: No.
The one's nine.
The others haven't really
started anything yet.
BEVERLEY TURNER: No.
I see our little girl is
the most competitive.
The middle one is the
most competitive.
Our nine-year-old has not got
this competitive drive at all.
He's a very, very
good swimmer.
And we're doing everything
we can to
encourage them at the moment.
But I think it's our
middle one I'm
going to have to watch.
Everything is a competition--
finishing desert, putting
your shoes on,
putting your coat on.
I won, Mommy!
So actually, in a way, with
her, I spend a lot of time
saying, it's not a competition,
Ki Ki.
And yet, with our eldest,
sometimes he
needs a bit of a push.
So I think they all sort
themselves out, whether they
want to be athletes or not.
JAMES CRACKNELL: No, I think
it's more they not specialize
too early is what I would say.
That if he came now, at nine,
saying I want to be a swimmer,
I would go, do you really want
to count tiles for the
rest of your life?
There's a reason why swimmers
give up at 25.
I think just to enjoy sports,
try many different ones.
And then, if you are best at the
one you enjoy most, then
that's the one for you.
We don't want to pressure
them into it.
But we're also not going to let
them give up straightaway.
BEVERLEY TURNER: And I think,
also, education as well.
That would be what I would--
you know we both-- well, I swam,
actually, so I'm just
ignoring the digs.
[LAUGHTER]
BEVERLEY TURNER: But we both
went to university.
I would encourage
them to do that.
But get your studies as well.
JAMES CRACKNELL: So we've got
a slightly bad place in our
house because her mom
is a swimming coach.
And her brother went to the
Athens Olympics in the British
swimming team, which
is brilliant.
Well, that was a bit of a jab.
[INAUDIBLE] used to come down.
You've get a very stiff back
rowing, generally, is one
thing that you kind of go, oh,
I've got this sore back today.
The coach would go,
just go swimming.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES CRACKNELL: So for me, it's
more rehab than a sport.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT BRITTIN: That's
about right.
JAMES CRACKNELL: And the coach
wouldn't go, just go and
scrummage for an hour
or something if
you've got a bad back.
But it really drilled home
swimming as the devil sport
when, at the Olympics--
BEVERLEY TURNER: [WHISPERS]
Answer the question.
MATT BRITTIN: Yes, OK--
the Olympics, that there's--
BEVERLEY TURNER: [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES CRACKNELL: Yes, OK.
Don't interrupt.
[INAUDIBLE].
BEVERLEY TURNER: [LAUGHS]
No.
Carry on.
JAMES CRACKNELL: That
[INAUDIBLE], her brother, was
competing as well.
And his two events were
on the same morning as
my heat and my semi.
And so I can understand Bev
going, her parents going.
But even my parents went
to watch him swim.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES CRACKNELL: And
their logic was,
you'll be in the final.
I was like, you haven't
got a by.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT BRITTIN: Very
unsupportive.
JAMES CRACKNELL: Yeah.
MATT BRITTIN: Very unsupportive
parents James had
is the answer to
that question.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
So I have a husband who
always has a crazy
running or cycling scheme.
And the latest one is like run
the Lebanon Mountain Trail,
not to give you any
ideas, of course.
But do you carry the veto
in your household?
So is there a time where
you can say, no,
you're not doing that?
Or do you feel like, no, just
kind of let James go?
BEVERLEY TURNER: I never did
before the accident.
I never said he couldn't
do something.
I'd look at the safety, look at
how it would work out with
the lifestyle.
But I completely trusted
him to go and do them.
Whereas, actually, post-accident
now, I kind of
go, no, that's not happening.
And then he actually did
an amazing trip--
again, the Discovery Channel
filmed it, which is to the
Yukon, which is the coldest
race on earth--
after the accident.
And I spent hours on the phone
to the medics, to the
insurance people, to
the production--
just making sure that
everything was
done to make it safe.
And that was the condition that
he had to go under, that
people he was with understood
the nature of his injury and
they understood him and knew him
well enough to know when
his behavior might be just
fatigue and when it might be
actually something that he was
actually struggling with.
I think, once you have children,
it's much easier to
make demands, because it's
a shared responsibility.
And I think you just have to
keep talking about them, don't
you, ultimately.
JAMES CRACKNELL: But the
other thing is--
BEVERLEY TURNER: And make sure
all the safety is in place
that possibly can be.
JAMES CRACKNELL: And that's a
really interesting question,
because the hardest
thing for me--
and we should go back to the
other question-- is being--
because when I had the accident
and woke up, that
everyone was used to me not
being me, because it had
been-- my first memories
are six or seven
weeks after the accident.
That everyone had become
normalized to
me not being quite--
first, not being at all
normal and then being
slightly more normal.
But I've had a couple of
seizures, which are related to
lack of sleep.
Although there's the three or
four hours where I don't
remember anything and
wake up in hospital.
It's been the reaction of having
been with Bev and our
kids beforehand, and then seeing
them a few hours later,
afterwards.
And for them, I was suddenly
the daddy that
was not well in Phoenix.
And that is why I hadn't seen
them before from me being
normal in the evening.
Then the next time I saw them, I
was the unwell person again.
Whereas, I actually felt OK.
It's just I had a seizure and
had to go to hospital.
Yeah, the bit I never saw of how
horrible it was for them,
it was really hard to me.
And that, whether it would be
the Atlantic or the South
Pole, a lot of it has been
going without sleep.
That's something that
I can't do any more.
So in terms of an event, that's
the one thing Bev will
always ask.
BEVERLEY TURNER: Yeah.
The epilepsy is quite a
big deal now for me.
JAMES CRACKNELL: Because after
every seizure, you can't drive
for a year.
So I've only been able to drive
for two weeks since the
accident three years ago, which
then places more stress
on Bev because she's the
only one who can drive.
So she's almost got four kids.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MATT BRITTIN: Thank
you, Michelle.
Another question?
AUDIENCE: Thanks, so
much for coming.
I was reading the other day that
the eight fastest rowers
don't necessarily make
the fastest boat.
JAMES CRACKNELL: I would
argue that, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
how you dealt with that.
Back in Athens, for instance,
you might have had four
fantastic athletes.
But how do you mold that
into a great team?
And link to that how
you dealt with your
row across the Atlantic.
Can I assume that you were,
perhaps, a slightly more
strong athlete than Ben?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Maybe?
JAMES CRACKNELL: Yeah.
No.
It was interesting going
to that event.
You think, well there's this
area of expertise where I will
have more understanding
or will be better at.
Actually, it's one small part of
the big jigsaw because, at
the Olympics, you do feel like
you're doing everything
because you're doing
all the training.
But you almost forget or ignore
the physiologist, the
coaches, the nutritionist,
other people helping you.
And when you have to do all of
that yourself, the rowing is
actually only a very
small part of that.
And a lot of it, as I said
before, was keeping positive,
make the right decisions at
the right time, and the
ability to keep going
is actually--
OK, when we were actually
rowing, would the boat get
faster when I was rowing it than
when he was rowing it?
Yeah.
It probably would.
But spread over 50 days and
3,000 miles, it gets reduced
significantly.
And I think it's the ability to
stay positive and determine
to hit your objective that
is as important,
rather than that speed.
So I think it does level out,
and especially as your
decisions you make
in that process
about the little things.
And ultimately, then it would
be the technology or the
equipment or something would let
you down that you had to
mend out there, because
you're [INAUDIBLE]
someone else.
MATT BRITTIN: James, just talk
about so your first gold was
Redgrave's last gold.
And you're in the boat
with him and Matt.
So there was quite
the expectation.
JAMES CRACKNELL: I felt
his fifth slightly
overshadowed my first.
MATT BRITTIN: Yes.
It was a bit rude of him.
But also, he was going through
all kinds of medical traumas
himself, his colitis and
everything else.
So you end up actually always
carrying the load that he was
bringing to the boat as well.
That must have been quite a
difficult team to put together
in that context.
JAMES CRACKNELL: It
was difficult.
And that's where rowing is,
as you know, Matt, is very
different from other sports.
It's not like playing football
for Barcelona.
And I'm sure they're all
good footballers.
But if I was playing for
Barcelona, I'd give the ball
to Messi as soon as possible.
With rowing, in a four-man boat,
you are only 25% of it.
Yet you're relying on three
other people to
deliver their 100%.
And you each do have a vaguely
specific role.
They're doing 90% of
the same thing.
You need to be stronger in
one area than the other.
And in the four hours in for,
say, the Sydney Olympics,
rowing with--
you think we've got 29 gold
medals in London.
We got one in Atlanta.
And that was Redgrave
and Pinsent.
But for me, coming in, yes,
there was the pressure of the
Olympic history from them.
But also, from my perspective,
was none of us had any gold
medals, because that's the
one we all wanted.
It didn't matter what you
had in your bag at home.
That was kind of irrelevant
on the start line.
And what I tried to get to them,
which annoyed them quite
a lot, was that what was good
enough there is not going to
be good enough now.
And so if you are going to
produce in four years what you
did four years ago and expect
to win, you're not going to
get anything.
AUDIENCE: You told them this?
JAMES CRACKNELL: I did
tell them that.
Yeah.
MATT BRITTIN: Daily,
from what was said.
JAMES CRACKNELL: Daily.
And basically, I would try to
just make sure I'd beat them
in training every day, because
it would generally annoy them
all for a while.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES CRACKNELL: And the more
angry they got, they would
probably take it out elsewhere
on the other people.
[LAUGHS]
MATT BRITTIN: That was actually
a great documentary
you guys made.
Was it gold--
JAMES CRACKNELL: "Gold
Fever," yeah.
MATT BRITTIN: "Gold Fever." If
you want to look on YouTube,
you'll find it.
JAMES CRACKNELL: Yeah.
BBC followed us for
four years.
Steve got diabetes.
And it was hard.
You think anyone you've met is
stubborn, you have no idea.
When he got told he had
diabetes, he wouldn't believe
the doctor.
And he would have a lack of
insulin, glycemic situation
where you'd find him
asleep in a corner.
And he would just refuse to
take it at that stage.
And even at the Olympic final,
I had sugar taped to my feet,
just in case he had
got it wrong.
It took him a few weeks
to realize, he may
actually have diabetes.
But he never, ever used
it as an excuse or
felt sorry for himself.
He was just, I've got something
I've got to deal with.
And that's fine.
MATT BRITTIN: It sounds like
you're taking that attitude to
your life at the moment.
So I think we have to
wrap it up there.
Huge thank you to Bev and
to James for coming.
[APPLAUSE]